if you just clicked on this video and
your first thought is why does that
person look like this then you know what
you are not a real council of geeks fan
okay so i'm gonna touch on a subject
that i haven't talked about in a while
and that is the
broad topic of toxic
fandom and i know that my just saying
the phrase is already going to set
some people off again i'm dealing with
this
broadly i may cite specific examples as
i go along
but this is not intended to be a
condemnation of any one specific
fandom these are topics and issues that
affect
all areas of fandom and not even just
like
geeky fandom this stuff that i'm about
to talk about today goes across the
board
as i said it's been a while since i've
talked about toxic fandom i have in the
past
talked about the ways in which fandoms
can kind of
go off the rails or um how
there is now these days sort of the
perceived idea that
an opinion is tied to a greater agenda
and isn't just an opinion anymore
this time i want to talk about something
that
doesn't feel like an evolution
or a recent development and honestly
kind of feels
heavily ingrained in the very nature of
fandom and how fans tend to interact
and that is gatekeeping so
gatekeeping if it's a term that you are
not familiar with
is the practice of sectioning off
what it means to be a fan and
what certain requirements someone should
meet before they are allowed
to say that they are a fan of something
it is a form of
shutting certain people out of the
conversation the community the fandom
and to a certain extent there is a
logical extrapolation going on with
it because it's not a completely
unreasonable thing for somebody to pull
doctor who because it's a fandom i'm
fairly involved
in that there is a bit of a
difference between somebody who
has been you know combing through every
single episode has seen every episode of
classic of modern heard every single
big finish and read all the target
novels and
someone who just started tuning in
during tenants era and stopped watching
after series four
to call them both fans in some ways does
at a gut level feel
a little disingenuous like there's
clearly a different of commitment
going on here right well yes
and i would say that you could debate
the
for lack of a better term size and scope
of the fan one is a fan of
much more of doctor who than the others
but you know what
they'd both still be fans and they'd
both still be valid and they would both
have a place in the fandom and that's
the thing about
gatekeeping by its nature it is an
exclusionary tactic
it is setting up barriers to entry
and honestly excessive amounts of
gatekeeping
can cause a community and a fandom
to stagnate and to shrink
and there is a protectiveness
especially with a lot of geeky
properties because
especially if you're anything close to
my age then
you remember a time when being into star
wars
got you made fun of reading superhero
comic books
and being very open about that might get
you picked on
this was the case once upon a time all
these things are mainstream now
and there is a fairly natural and
understandable inclination
to want to separate the people who have
been there for lack of a less cliched
term
before it was cool and the people who
are in on it now
but you don't help a fandom
by being exclusionary
the thing about gatekeeping is it can
start
understandably and it can even start
from a positive place
of being like oh you like this thing
well
have you seen this yet have you read
this yet
you haven't oh you should if you like
this thing if you're a fan of this
here's other parts of it that you don't
know about yet you're gonna have such a
good time
and it's a depressingly
short step to go from that
to what you haven't seen this
and this and you haven't read that how
can you even call yourself
a fan a big takeaway that i want people
to realize is
even though i sort of made the
comparison you know people my age
you know having the whole i liked it
before was cool thing
fandom gatekeeping is not new
it's been there since certainly for as
long as i
have been aware that fandom was even a
thing
i remember in grade school that
there were there were some kids in my
class
and around my age and a little older who
did like star wars
and i remember them making fun of some
kids in the lower grade like first and
second grade because those kids
liked the ewok cartoon
because in the eyes of the more mature
and more real fans
that was the stupid kitty spin-off no
real fan would like that they couldn't
view it as a stepping stone
for someone to get into the greater
world of star wars they just demean them
for it
so this mentality of
sectioning off and creating a hierarchy
within the fandom of saying that these
kinds of fans are better than
these kinds of fans is
as old as fandom this has always been
around
what gatekeeping becomes is it becomes a
somewhat harsher line
but it is a very natural outgrowth of
fandom hierarchies which honestly i
would say shouldn't exist in the first
place
you could certainly make a knowledge
that someone is a more
knowledgeable fan about something but to
say that someone is a
better fan a superior fan
because they know more of these things
because they have seen
more things because they have read more
things
that doesn't make you better than
somebody else
not as a person or as a fan it just
means you have what you love
and you've gotten into it deeper and
that's great
and somebody else is taking joy from it
by doing something more like skimming
the surface but they're still
taking joy they still get to call
themselves
a fan they have to be able to call
themselves a fan
because if they're not you will never
have new fans
and the thing is sometimes i really get
the impression that
these gatekeeping elitist
people in the fandom community don't
want new fans some of them i
think will actually actively tell you
that they don't want new people
they don't want new voices they don't
want
things to change and they i think at
some level
fear that if new people are here who
aren't me
and if their hook into this thing is
something other than
what hooked me in then maybe to appeal
to them
the franchise will become something else
and that's the real insidious thing
about phantom gatekeeping is it becomes
a way
that if a franchise goes in a different
direction than what you would like
or what it was when you fell in love
with it
you start taking it out on other fans
we've watched over the past few years as
fandom after fandom has cannibalized
itself
as the old guard
tears apart the newcomers
it's happened to star wars
it's happened to doctor who
there's been that kind of thing going on
at star trek for
a long dang time that one certainly has
been dealing with this sort of thing for
a while
i know that if you care something about
something deeply
that it is at best
disappointing when it changes into
something that
doesn't speak to you anymore and you
feel
pushed away and i can even understand a
certain
amount of anger behind that
but to take that out and to blame it
on other people who also like this
but just like it for their own reasons
because oh my god heaven forbid
individual people have different takes
on something and you can like different
elements of something
than oth than someone else and that's
fine
that somehow it's their fault basically
just for existing
the very existence of fans who
don't clear the gate
can and has been twisted into some kind
of threat
to the franchise
simply by them being there they taint it
just trying to enjoy the thing that they
love
that you love no fandom no franchise
can survive without new blood
and there's some gatekeepers who will
even acknowledge that and will say
something along the lines of well it's
not that we don't want new fans
we just want the right kind of fan
the kind that will not rock the boat
that will not come in
with new perspectives that won't come in
to this batman fandom saying
i like i like it when robin was in
short shorts and and said catch phrases
they don't want that because to some
fans batman
is a dark and broody loner and the very
fact that he has a brightly colored
sidekick
in and of itself already irks them
and if somebody likes batman for that
element
well then that's not a real fan
but real fan is
always code for one thing
and one thing only it is code for
fan that holds the same opinion that i
do
because as much as gatekeepers want you
to believe
that there is some sort of community
consensus
on what a real fan is
there's not you might find clusters
who will say well it's this but you know
what they
infight as well because some will say
well you have to
at least have seen all these things and
i will say no
you you have to do they can't even agree
but even if they could even if there was
some kind of community consensus for
what qualifies as a real fan
it would still be wrong
if you like something if you enjoy it
if it brings light into your life
whether it be
for a lifetime or just for however long
it takes you to take it in the one time
but it leaves behind pleasant memories
you are allowed to call yourself a fan
of that
if you wish and anyone who tries to tell
you that you're not a real fan
they apparently just want a locked off
community
that will stagnate stop growing
and eventually die
i wouldn't want that for a property that
i love
why do you
gatekeeping toxic fandom
i went a little bit unstructured on this
one these are sort of my broad
philosophical and a bit of a event
on the topic because like i said it's
not new
but it also is not going away anytime
soon so that's my thoughts on the record
about that kind of fandom behavior
just stop so thank you very much for
watching
i have a patreon that keeps this entire
operation up and running it this is in
fact
at this point how i am making my living
barely
but that this is happening at this point
i'm also currently running a kickstarter
for a novel
there is a link to that down in the
description plus
social media merch all that stuff and
like share subscribe
leave your comments let me know what you
think about what i've had to say
but you also don't have to
because i don't get to dictate what it
means
to be a member of the council
because you are the council
and i am just running the meetings and
until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
um
bye